this is like nothing I've ever
experienced I know there were some
analogies like you said 9/11 I saw this
great tweet from this guy his name is yi
Shan Wang do you know if you know who he
is he's he was a former CEO of reddit he
was like an expert guy see you've read
it for a while
really smart guy I love following him on
Twitter he doesn't have that many
followers but he says a lot of smart
that I just basically steal and
then say myself later and he was saying
he was like you know the coronavirus
thing is so different from like the last
thing that felt like this was 9/11 and
he goes this is so much harder for
Americans he's like because when it was
9/11 the response was all bravery
patriotism action revenge it was all
action things and there was a clear
visible enemy it was like okay you don't
sort of a terrorist bin Laden you got
this picture in your brain that you
could sort of point it to is it with
this we have an invisible enemy you
can't see the virus you don't know who
has it you don't know who doesn't so we
all just have to hide and the best
course of action is inaction and that's
very strange for people and it reminds
me of this quote by Pascal which is like
all of man's problems
come down to butchering the quote but
it's like all of man's problems come
down to the fact that he cannot sit
alone in a room for thirty minutes being
able to just sit in your house and chill
and it's so difficult for people you
know it's funny there's I was talking to
a co-worker I'm like there's two things
that a lot of people want and then they
get it and it freaks them out and this
is a little taste of that which is
people talk about retiring they want
enough money that they can retire and a
lot of people want to work from home and
I've gotten a lot of from the work
from home crowd because I'm because I
keep saying I hate this I hate it I love
coming into the office and feeling
energy and I've retired what not retired
I took I've taken eight months off at a
time and it gets boring fast and what
we're seeing now is that some people are
you can kind of taste it a little bit
and I personally hate it
so okay I got the quote because I
butchered it all of humanity's problems
stem from man's inability to sit quietly
in a room alone okay that's the quote I
had to correct it because it's small
[Music]
you